من اكثر الاعمال الرمضانيه اللي محيط فيها
جدل وكلام هو مسلسل دفعه لندن اللي في نفس
الوقت محقق نجاح جماهيري ومتابعه كبيره
جدا المسلسل بيتكلم عن مجموعه من طلبه
الجامعه من مختلف الجنسيات بيختاروا
الدراسه وكل واحد فيهم حامل افكار
ومعتقداته رسائل مختلفه عن الاخر دفعت
لندن هو ثالث عمل دفعه للكاتبه هبه مشاري
حماده فسبقوا دفعه القاهره ودفعه بيروت
واللي كمان احاطهم برضو كثير جدل دفعت
لندن من اولى حلقاته محط جدل هو كمان سواء
من تعليقات على جراه في الطرح والكرام
مرورا باحداث اعتبرها ناس غير منطقيه مثل
انه الاميره ديانا لجات لطلاب كويتيين في
مره كذا وهي هربانه من نهايه بالجدل
الاكبر وهو الاتهامات بالاساءه للعراقيين
والسبب انه في المسلسل فيه شخصيه عراقيه
بتطلب تشتغل انه كعاملات في منازل او في
منزل
الكويتيين وبتتهم بالسرقه
هنشوفنا الساعات الماضيه الصناع دفعه لندن
بيطلعوا بيردوا فكاتبه العمل هبه مشاري
حماده ردت على احد منتقديه العمل على
انستجرام وقالت انه تاريخ العراق اكبر من
انه يخبرها عنه المشحونين عاطفيا وقصيري
النظر اللي ما في فكرهم الا مخ المؤامره
وقالت انه اللي بيتابع العمل بيشوف انه
الفتاه العراقيه اللي بتعمل كعامله او
خادمه كانت ابنه استاذ تاريخ تم اعدامه
وصديقه اللي امنوا على بناته اللي عندهم
ثروه كبيره سرقهم وتركهم من دون اي شيء
وقالت انه الهدف هو اسقاط سرقه العراق من
العراقيين وسرقه تاريخها تحديدا وتراثها
ومستقبل ابنائها بسبب الحرب والخلافات
وقالت انه الغيره والحماس اخذت الناس اللي
بعيد وانها بتغار على تاريخ وفكر العراق
اكثر من اي احد ليلى عبد الله وهي ايضا
احدى نجمات العمل طلعت وردت هي كمان في
مقطع فيديو ورددها تحديدا قالت له يعني او
انه تحديدا على منتقديه كلمه قالتها احدى
شخصيه المسلسل واعتبروها الناس جريئه
ليش دائما احنا يعني مثلا احنا اغراضنا
اغراض بنات ما يصير نقول حرام عيب كل شيء
بالخشوه كل شيء يعني ما ينقال انا اشوف ما
ادري انا اشوفه مبالغه بالنفاق صراحه يعني
انا كل مره قاعد اشوف نفاق زياده وزياده
انا بالنسبه لك ليلى انا قاعد ابرر حق ولا
احد انا بالنسبه لك ليلى انا احس انه انه
اعيد مو تبرير حق ولا احد انا احس ان
الكلمه ما فيها شيء اللويا اللي مسوينها
على دفعه لندن اللي قماشه راف محمد شلون
قالت الكلمه هذه انا ما اشوف انه فيها شيء
غلط اغراض البنات اغراضنا احنا كلنا مو
عيب
ولا حرام
انا اشوف انه هذا شيء عادي
يعني
ودي اقول عن القضيه الثانيه
لكن ان شاء الله كل شيء بوقتها حلو يعني
كل شيء يعني بسولف عنه بس كل شي بوقته حلو